hey guys so we're in the car on our way
to Palm Springs for Coachella
I've never been to Coachella before and
we're heading up to the style Hall house
they got an awesome house for some of
their creators and were pretty excited
about it because I'd only go to go to
Coachella and I've never really wanted
to camp in the desert although as fun as
that sounds
doesn't actually sound very fun at all
we're only good at camping if like
there's like resources closed
yeah like Starbucks we go to Starbucks
choice Jenna just tweeted about it
I am not proud of it best with this song
tiresome time for our skip the lyrics up
I know this part kami one good reason
why I should never make a change Georgia
is right you're the best ally mm-hmm we
shout for hours so what time is it right
now
552 552 will update you soon I got
really tired all of a sudden and I'm
concerned because I am the driver well
I'm assuming you'll probably make like
an hour and really hate me to drive and
I'll be like very fine
wait I definitely feel the beat even
look no I'm sorry wait Friday April 10th
at 2:30 to 35 that is the only thing I
want to do is go see George Ezra thing
give you other reason why I should never
play but she too long the words bite
either it's 7:01 we've currently only
gone 1012 miles we've got 12 miles if
it's good an hour and a half or so I
think but what did I last a jacket looks
like five five seventy was five
something it definitely was we're done
we're not going well we're actually
moving now oh my gosh
what is your problem okay I have to pee
so bad Jenna I have to pee and I also
need to get film for my camera so we
have to go to target we have to target
what are you waiting for what you
waiting we wasted so much time shopping
for Coachella we could've just came to
target actually freaking cute this is
freaking cute this is freaking cute
these are all freaking cute yep so we
have a stop because we think what's our
odds what do you think I think it might
be open should we even bother getting
gas should I get gas okay here now we
just randomly stopped to get gas because
we thought the truck was open so like
I'm at a gas station
we have been goin anywhere and we still
have an hour and a half until we
make it are we is this is this tank oh
my gosh music tanks so we just got to
the house and this is absolutely
ridiculous this is the anjaana's bed
dead we bunk an up girl
this is like the lovers suite oh my god
this is bigger than the entire room what
is this
look at this bathtub oh wait I'm sorry
what oh my gosh this is like yeah this
room is bigger than my home this is
bigger than my home good good oh my gosh
oh my god if this was my closet I would
this is bigger than my house Oh Jenna
please come over this is like a freaking
laundromat this is what they have at the
dry cleaners okay if you ever have this
much crap for one single human you've
got a problem I am overwhelmed this
place is ridiculous
I don't even like their I don't even
know who else is here oh my goodness a
little outside hot tub turn up man
turn up